le titre de nos confrères de libération
drôles de dames le quotidien propose
aujourd'hui un entretien avec carla
bruni sarkozy
elle y parle musique de son rôle de sa
place auprès du chef de l'état de ce
dédoublement un côté artiste et en même
temps première dame de france pierre
monnet gier et damien louvet avant
d'être la première dame de france elle
était et elle est toujours chanteuse une
victoire de la musique deux albums et
tout à coup l'ancien mannequin converti
à la musique ajoute une nouvelle corde à
sa guitare épouse du chef de l'état
entre deux visites officielles elle
continue de composer
il sort un nouvel album a situation
maritale exceptionnel promotion inédite
cinq pages dans libération une interview
diffusée sur le site internet du journal
carla bruni sarkozy joue la transparence
doit-on lui définir un statut elle
préfère ironiser
ce qui n'est pas des spécialistes qui
peuvent tout trouvé mais faut un chef
d'état sortant personne j'aime beaucoup
laurent pelly et en tant que ministre je
ne m'exprimais pas ce que ge a par cette
chose de tests adn qui lui a donc un peu
échappé
en tant que ministre je crois que c'est
je le jugerais pas je n'ose pas me
prononcer la liberté de parole à ses
limites
mais ni l'elysée ni carla bruni sarkozy
non relue l'interview libération se
défend d'avoir participé à un plan média
vivons une situation inédite en france
au nom de quoi faudrait-il s'interdire
d'interviewer la chanteuse parce qu'elle
s'appelle madame sarkozy
je trouve que ce serait la renvoyer un
rôle d épouse ce serait réducteur ce
serait machiste au nom de croiser
faudrait-il ignorer le rôle politique
qu'elle joue son troisième album sortira
le 11 juillet prochain
la première dame versera l'intégralité
des royalties à la fondation france